Дональд Трамп стверджує, що мігранти відповідальні
за зростання злочинності у ФРН.
Чи є в цьому  доля правди?
Погляньмо на цифри!
У 2017 році кількість зафіксованих злочинів
у Німеччині впала на майже 10 відсотків,
до найнижчої позначки з 1992 року
Рівень злочинності, який вимірюється кількістю кримінальних правопорушень
на 100 тисяч населення, також упав.
Кількість скоєних у Німеччині злочинів дійсно зросла у 2015 та 2016 роках
у період, коли понад мільйон мігрантів прибули до ФРН.
Однак зросла вона і у рік перед кризою біженців.
Тож варто проаналізувати цифри детальніше,
аби зрозуміти, чи є зв'язок між мігрантами та злочинністю.
Саме це вже зробила Федеральна поліція Німеччини.
Цьогоріч вона оприлюднила звіт про злочинність в контексті міграції.
Ось що вдалося з'ясувати.
Є певні види злочинів, яких побільшало, а частка підозрюваних
у їхньому скоєнні, які є мігрантами, злегка зростає.
А саме: жорстокі дії;
наркозлочини та сексуальні злочини
щоправда, їхню кількість важко аналізувати,
бо офіційне визначення було змінено.
В останні роки мігрантами та шукачами притулку
було скоєно низку серйозних та гучних злочинів.
Однак статистика засвідчує, що кількість мігрантів
у якості підозрюваних у скоєнні злочинів іде на спад.
Минулого року було зареєстровано скорочення на 10 відсотків.
І це попри той факт, що у Німеччині нині живуть
більше мігрантів, ніж раніше.
Офіційна кримінальна статистика показує, що
міграція має вплив на види скоюваних у Німеччині злочинів.
Проте категоричне твердження Дональда Трампа про те,
що злочинність у Німеччині зростає,
відколи прибули мігранти, - неправильне.